notre sommaire ce soir quatre livres
seulement max pol fouchet temps malade
nous regrettons de romain gary vengeur
des toiles
gabriel véral des espions de bonne
volonté de rené à l'eau le guide
mystérieux de versailles en commençant
par les compagnons de la forêt noire de
michel droit mais j'ai le droit
ce roman est le premier volume engins on
dit d'un triptyque mais là il s'agit de
quatre espagnols ensemble de quatre 4
volumes qui seront l'histoire de notre
temps de 45 à 65 70 show ce prénom
oui c'est un cycle qui s'appellera qui
s'appelle déjà
le temps des hommes l'idée si vous
voulez l'été l'idée directrice de ce
cycle est partie de ceux ci j'ai
toujours été très très frappé par la
coïncidence qui avait existé pour les
gens de notre génération c'est à dire
pour ceux qui avaient 20 21 22 ans en
1944 1945
la coïncidence qui avait existé pour eux
entre leurs passages assez brutale
presque sans transition de l'adolescence
à l'âge d'homme et le passage de leur
pays de la france de l'état de pays
occupé à l'état de pays en devenant peu
à peu souverain et je crois que cette
coïncidence a été a joué un très grand
rôle sur nous je crois que nous avons
des pendus beaucoup d'elle vous savez on
dit toujours que la génération
romantique celle qui a connu son
épanouissement sous la monarchie de
juillet par exemple était parti de 1815
que 1815 avait été la date la date
décisive bien je crois que notre eu
notre 1815 nous ça a été 1945 alors je
voudrais essayer de raconter en quatre
romands n'ont pas bien entendu
l'histoire de cette de cette génération
de notre génération ce qui serait
beaucoup trop ambitieux mais l'aventuré
romanesque d'un certain nombre d'hommes
de notre génération choisi de façon à
choisi par par choix affectif par
élections tout à fait même mvb
arbitraire et de raconter cette histoire
2945 c'est à dire de son point de départ
jusqu'à
jusqu'à 1970 c'est à dire sur un quart
de siècle étant entendu que ce ne sera
jamais dû du roman fiction car si je
respecte mon programme j'aurais plutôt
tendance à prendre du retard sur lui que
de la vence j'ai créé mon quatrième
roman
quatrièmement de ce cycle en 1972
c'est à dire lorsque je saurai ce qui a
pu arriver à mes héros entre 66 et 70
maintenant pourquoi avoir commencé par
un roman de guerre par ronan qui se
situe durant les derniers mois durant
des deux dernières semaines même de la
guerre en allemagne plus de se vendre
il avait du talent en 1815 et 1945 c'est
un peu la même chose 1815 et les
romantiques est ce que croyait que le
mot romantique et doit être remplacé par
un autre en ce qui le concerne je ne
sais pas je crois que le mot romantique
et toutes les générations je crois qu'il
ya toujours une certaine façon
romantique peut envisager la vie je
crois par exemple que d'une certaine
façon ce ce roman les cobayes de la
forêt noire à un certain certains un
certain romantisme alors je vous disais
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai choisi de
raconter les derniers mois de la guerre
en allemagne ya parce que je crois que
pour tous ceux de notre génération qui
ont eu la chance de vivre cette
extraordinaire aventure brève mais mais
fulgurante et très plein que fut la
campagne d'allemagne de la première
armée française du général de l'ade
campagne qu'on a souvent tendance
maintenant quelques fois oublié ou
escamotées derrière d'autres faits moins
important mais enfin c'est une autre
histoire
je crois que pour ceux qui ont eu la
chance de vivre cette campagne
d'allemagne
cela a été extraordinaire cela fut aussi
décisif pour eux vous imaginez ce que
c'était pour des des garçons qui était
passé de 16 à 20 ans ou de 17 à 21 ans
dans un pays vaincu occupé humilié et
qui avait ressenti tout cela comme une
blessure et avec une amertume
d'autant plus forte qu'il se sentait eux
mêmes très jeune très fragile très
traite des armées pour changer le cours
des choses
vous imaginez ce que ce fut pour eux que
de pénétrer les armes à la main sur le
territoire sur le sol de ce qu'ils
avaient vaincu leurs aînés de devenir à
leur tour des combattants de devenir des
vainqueurs des conquérants des occupants
c'était c'était quelque chose de
d'extraordinaire d'extraordinaire
extraordinaire la découverte de la
puissance évidemment nous savions bien
que nous ne devions notre présence là un
cas nous allier qui avait changé le
destin de la guerre nous savions bien
que que l'armée allemande n'était plus
qu elle avait été en 41 42
bien qu'elles luttent encore des
réactions terrible mais je crois quand
on a 20 21 ans et qu'on vit une aventure
aussi grisante en eux on ne s'arrête pas
de tels détails
alors ça nous a ça nous a marqué je
dirais même plus que marqué je dirais
que ça nous a ça nous à laver ça nous a
libéré une seconde fois de façon plus
importante encore que la première
quelques mois plus tôt parce que cette
libération de la recension vraiment et
nous nous la donne y ont en même temps
vous voyez ça a été un peu je dirais pas
notre éducation sentimentale mais notre
éducation viril
ça a été l'expérience vous l'avez fait
personnellement je les fait je les fait
personnellement j'ai eu la chance de la
faire et voyez si si j'avais écrit mon
roman selon la technique des romanciers
du nouveau roman et si je lui avais
cherché un titre très rageant nouveau
roman c'est à dire un titre un peu
abstrait m'exprimant quand même ce que
j'avais voulu y mettre
je crois que je n'aurais appelé la
réhabilitation car ce fut vraiment pour
nous une réhabilitation qui nous a qu'à
presque peut-être dans une certaine
mesure sauvé notre notre vie d'homme
alors je ne pouvais pas commencer ce
cycle sur l'histoire de quelques hommes
de ma génération puisque j'avais la
liberté romanès du soir venait sq sans
raconter cette réhabilitation sans
essayer de le raconter pour gauthier qui
est quelqu'un non pas qui vous
ressemblent mais quelqu'un qui à votre
âge notre âge d'ailleurs à ce moment là
qu'est ce que c'est ce qu'il vit et
qu'est ce que c'est que ce roman dont il
est le héros 7 c'est une prise de
conscience des autres louise ans des
jeux qui combattent avec lui ce roman
donc et l'histoire de quelques jeunes
hommes qui au lendemain de la libération
de paris s'engage de quelques jeunes
hommes très différents de milieux très
différentes formations les uns des
autres qui ne se connaissent pas et qui
se retrouvent dans un régiment issu de
la résistance
gimont de ftp parisien régiment qui lui
même rejoint la première armée française
en alsace est intégrée elle alors le
roman commence quelques mois plus tard
en avril au moment où la campagne
d'allemagne commencer le même et ce
roman se déroule au hasard de l'accord
en allemagne de la campagne à main c'est
à dire d'abord en forêt noire d'où son
titre ensuite autour de stuttgart dans
le bulletin vert après ça vers le danube
mais je crois hélas je vais répondre à
votre votre question je crois que tous
les combats que je peux raconter ne sont
dans le fond qu une écorce qu'un décor
qu'un prétexte et que ce n'est pas leur
histoire le roman j'ai voulu écrire
c'est plutôt l'histoire d'une prise de
conscience et même de deux différentes
prises de conscience d'abord prise de
conscience pour les héros de mon livre
pour les principaux héros de ce que
représentent leurs camarades qui sont
comme je voulais dit très différent
d'eux qui représente quelque chose de
tout à fait inconnu presque presque
insoupçonnées pour eux car il est
évident que c'est la prise de conscience
justement de par françois gauthier qui
est le héros principal du roman qui est
un jeune étudiant le milieu bourgeois
catholique prise de conscience de ce qu
est un jeune intellectuel israélite
comme simon ayem qui lui ne s'est engagé
que dans l'idée d'aller délivrer ses
parents qui ont été déportés par les
allemands qui se trouve dans un camp de
concentration
évidemment c'est une idée très
chimérique il le sait bien il sait qu'il
ne la réalisera jamais il sait que ses
parents sont probablement morts mais
c'est l'étoile qu'il guide est prise de
conscience également de la part toujours
de la part de françois gauthier
étudiants bourgeois catholique de skate
jeunes militants jeunes ouvriers
communistes comme guérin qui est à la
fois partisans et généreux et puis prise
de conscience réciproque évidemment
prise de conscience aussi de ce que sont
les chefs sous les ordres duquel ils
combattent et que j'ai essayé de rendre
à ses caractéristiques des différents
types d'officiers qui lie à l'état à la
première armée française officier de
carrière officiers de réserve officiers
ftp ffi il est évident que si le colonel
du régiment le colonel garraud qui est
un officier de carrière d'officier de
l'armée d'afrique qui a combattu ans en
italie en tunisie est très différent de
son adjoint le colonel bernard qui est
un ftp un ancien des brigades
internationales
un ancien la surrection de paris le
colonel gao lui même qui est un officier
de carrier avec et tonifier sorti du
rang est aussi très différent du
capitaine beany qui se trouve sous ses
ordres qui lui est vraiment le jeune
officier de tradition ce qu'on appelait
avant la guerre le fana de l'armée qui
est sorti de saint cyr en 39 qui a
toujours eu la vocation de l'armée dont
l'armée est toujours représenté la
religion l'idéal suprême et qui a reçu
comme une maison de six étages sur les
épaules
là la défaite de 40 qui en a été blessé
pour la vie et qui considère cette fois
dans l'action que j'ai essayé d'écrire
qui considère comme son purgatoire sur
terre de servir dans une dans une unité
de ffi de soldats amateurs pour lui
presque d'irrégulier et puis alors je
crois aussi qu à travers l'allemagne
vaincue à travers les villes que l'on
prend à travers les hommes qui tombent à
travers les camps l'horreur des camps de
concentration que l'on découvre les
prisonniers que l'on fait ce qu'on
délivre il y a la prise de conscience
pour tous ces hommes du courage et de la
peur du risque du sacrifice de la vie et
de la mort et il y a finalement pour le
héros françois gauthier au moins pour
lui il y a lorsque la guerre s'achève et
le roman aussi la prise de conscience de
ce qu'on est et ses quelques semaines de
guerre pour lui ces quelques mois de
guerre pour lui de la transition
ils ont été entre deux âges de sa vie
entre l'adolescence et la vie d'homme et
se rend compte qu'au fond ils n'ont
peut-être été qu'un grand entracte
davanture de risque d'éducation viril
mais un entracte décisif qui aura décidé
en grande partie de lui même et qu'il
leur a fait passer justement beaucoup
plus rapidement de l'âge de
l'adolescence qui désormais est mort
pour lui autant des hommes qui commence
et kiki et strauss père le sujet les
autres romans en 45 encore plus que
maintenant il y avait les perdants et
les gagnants
il y avait ceux qui s'est engagé il ya
la victoire et les ordres il ya tous
marty com vous aide marty comme gauthier
partie est-ce que
laure l'occasion rencontrer les perdants
celui il ya toujours dans toutes les
histoires les gagnants et les perdants
en particulier dans ce gymnase
oui c'était très sensible à ce moment la
salle l'a été au cours d'événements
récents que nous avons connue là étant
donné le temps durant lequel se déroule
le roman quelques semaines et son
périmètre d'action assez restreint une
unité militaire
là il y a des perdants mais il joue un
rôle à sec 3/10 qu on les croise par la
suite les autres romans essaieront de
plongée dans les événements nous avons
vécu depuis 1945
48 je ne dis pas qu'ils seront à
l'intérieur de ces événements mais en
face les événements se dérouleront
parallèlement tels des événements au
cours desquels il ya eu effectivement
des gagnants et des perdants
eh bien on verra dans dans mes romans je
pense si tout se passe comme je l ai
prévu des gagnants et des perdants
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire le
découpage en année le découpage et un
découpage de de ce cycle le tel que je
le vois maintenant ça changera peut être
cours de route
là donc c'est la fin de la guerre et en
dix dernières semaines de la guerre est
certain nombre de retours en arrière sur
les années d'occupation
le deuxième roman qui devrait paraître
dans deux ans commencera je crois en
1950 à peu près et se terminera vers
1954 c'est à dire s'ils viennent faux
nom de jalon historique
il commencera au moment du début de la
guerre de corée et il se terminera au
mans de dien ben phu
ce qui ne veut pas dire d'ailleurs la
kaaba sera absolument pas dien bien phu
m'enfin ce sont les jalons situé en en
fond de décor le troisième qui devrait
paraître deux ans après c'est à dire en
1970-71 le troisième lui se déroulera en
gros de 1956 à 1962 c'est à dire là
encore suez si vous voulez suez budapest
et la dépendance de l'algérie et le le
quatrième est bien le quatrième principe
de 65 66 et 70
[Musique]